i got accepted to the robotics team
and i participated in first robotics
competitions for five years was the best
experience of my life and they changed
me completely
they gave me my confidence back they
gave me my english they gave me my
entrepreneurial skills they exposed me
to so many things
and um and so in my last year 2018 we
won semi-world champions
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel
j impact
leap google for startups and hippo and
in media partnership with ctec
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders i
am so excited to be hosting my pianta
the ceo and co-founder of v for a very
very interesting episode 22 year old mai
piamenta co-founder and ceo of v founded
v together with her two partners gil and
avi to make social impact easier than
ever
since her teenage years mai has been
passionate about volunteerism before
founding veeam 2019 she led a global
nonprofit team where she managed 10
million volunteers in over 32 countries
all the work was done manually and she
found existing technological solutions
to be enterprise oriented and difficult
to use
so she decided to act and today we're
going to hear a story thank you mike
[Music]
i'm so proud to to be a very very small
part of this journey thank you for
allowing me to take part a as a small
investor but but really that you're on a
mission to
to make a significant impact not just on
organizations but by virtue on a lot of
a lot of different and non-profits and
by virtue a lot of people around the
world that are going to be benefiting
from the work that you're doing at this
i'm excited to unpack a little bit about
what v is and and even more importantly
who mai is and and how does mai and v
sort of coexist together and and your
why so might tell me a little bit about
yourself you have a different type of a
background first because of of your age
as a ceo of an awesome company but tell
me a little bit about you know who you
are and how did you end up starting v
yeah i mean you're right um a bit
different background but
um just for everybody here they will
listen to us uh my in new york on may so
i need to correct everyone that it's my
um so my i'm 22.
um originally from limona i'm not from
the tel aviv area that everyone you know
knows um so i grew up in demona as a
small town in southern israel and um i'm
the eldest i have two siblings
and hilar
both younger than me
and they're amazing i love them and i
grew up you know to have family
great parents um not connected to tech
in any way
super super old-fashioned um and you
know in workforce and
um when i
was eight
i lost my best friend to cancer
her name was a flat
and
frat and i we were best friends
neighbors together all the time
um she wouldn't let anyone else to
be with her when she takes medicine
exceptive of myself and we were super
close
and after a couple years she passed away
from the cancer disease and
um after she passed away i took with my
with myself and on my heart the feeling
that i want to give back to her for all
the values and everything we've you know
been through together
and
uh when i was 13 i saw an article
of the juan menosem the israeli
non-profit that supports cancer
um you know kids that suffer from cancer
and
i saw an article of the juan manahem
requesting girls to join their effort
and
cut the hair and help them with wigs uh
prep you know preparation is and also
unique uh calling for girls
for to donate their roots um and donate
their roots for cancer um law hair loss
uh research
so i saw this article and i knew that it
has to be me and i need to do that and
i'm not i'm not no i'm not gonna do it
like like everyone else i want to go big
time i want to cut my entire hair i was
13.
wow so i came to my mom
saying mom i'm cutting my hair i'm
shaving everything i want to donate it i
want to help them and she told me you're
crazy you're never gonna do that
oh this stuff that mom has to say when
her daughter comes up with a speech
the day after i had no hair
no way
no yeah
here we're going to have a picture i
guess if we're if we are doing our
editing right
of my with no yeah i had no idea that
that's
wow that's that's incredible at 13 i can
only imagine
well the next day
um as a 13 year old with nowhere that's
that's not a it was terrible
wow it was terrible i like like from
being you know
a new girl and you know high school or
let's say mid school i came and i looked
like a boy i had a hat on my hair i'm
gonna give you pictures of everything so
you can just make a joke out of it but
it was super super super oh it's weird
and
especially at that age um and i came
home the day after and my grandfather
saw me it's like you're insane
and i bought a wig i was so ashamed
going you know walking around with no
hair that i bought the wig and my
grandfather uh took the week and put it
in the trash tell me you
just cannot
uh let yourself be so you know
um give this hair so much space in your
confidence and
hey he just threw it away and from this
day i was with no
and um
i suffered from terrible
um you know let's say kids violence it's
not you know actual violence but you
know um
having no hair and you know seventh
grade was a big challenge so i shifted
and i moved to the into the you know
other school in de mona wow and lucky me
i landed in the day you know the school
and the day that were they were hiring
and recruiting
for the robotics team
and the school
so i it's like okay i'll go and i'll see
what it is and i signed
up for two um
for two majors one was fashion one was
robotics um and i did both so with my
fashion side i opened a website of
swimwear and i ran it for a year it was
super cool but then i um then i got
accepted to the robotics team
and i participated in first robotics
competitions for five years was the best
experience of my life
and they changed me completely
they gave me my confidence back they
gave me my english they gave me my
entrepreneurial skills they exposed me
to so many things
and um and so in my last year 2018 we
won semi-world champions and western
texas
uh this team from dimona
i love this i'm i'm sending this
straight to dean cayman who who created
first robotics i think
he'll it'll it'll put such a big smile
on his face this is that that is
tell me a little bit about
your transition so you're mentioning
transition to the new school
i i was suffered from massive bullying
as a kid as well coming back from the us
and
transition school as well so i can
empathize a little bit with with the
situation but sort of this robotics and
the different entrepreneurial things
that you were doing and i'll i'll
classify them as entrepreneurial for now
tell me a little bit about the
confidence that it instilled in you and
how did this shape
sort of your outlook now you're still i
mean you're still 22 you now you're
you're you're you're following that that
same path as a ceo of an amazing company
what did that do to you sort of growing
up
that's such an incredible question
because
when
when i did something you know when i
shaved my hair i did something for a
good cause
and when you get such terrible response
from people
it doesn't make sense
right i mean
i did something for such a beautiful
cause
and i came to school proud of myself
and then you get such terrible responses
from all around
um
it contradicted you know in my head and
i was like okay i don't want to be here
i want to be around people that will
understand the purpose of what i did
and i think that from
this day that i moved it was longer than
that i came to my mom saying i'm not
going back there
whether you're sending me to the second
school or i'm not going
um and you know eventually they had to
because i was so um you know
um persistent about it so when i came
and came to them when i'm taking this
experience let's say today
i
know that for me
both as a founder a ceo a friend
a girlfriend whatever um
a colleague
i always want to see the reason of why a
person does something whether if it's
good or bad because the reason means so
much
you know ex looking from the outside my
mom got sms messages is my okay
does my have cancer
i mean the the out the outside and the
external look and the external image of
a person can say a thousand different
things
understanding the reason and the purpose
and where a person comes from
can change the picture completely and
this is what i embraced from this
experience as a person
incredible i mean it's uh i mean i'm
sure that we can unpack so much more
you know what's you know your your
journey up until now um tell me a little
bit about the formation of v because
you're talking about the reason the why
the giving back it sounds like he is
sort of encompassing a lot of these
experiences you've had into one coherent
strategy in in a very scalable way so so
what what is v first of all
yeah so v is the network of good
as we call it
so we're building the network of good
that will collect and and let's say
connect people from all around the world
around social missions whether they're
the mission creators what are the people
that are coming and helping the missions
now it's only through volunteering but
soon to be in
many many more uh channels of help like
donations and more um and
in our vision v is not just helping the
nonprofits or the people that own the
missions to scale them and to get help
but eventually we aim that our
technology and platform will eventually
connect the people that need help
directly with the people that help them
and this is our
uh this mission and um we monetize this
beautiful thing by helping the larger
organizations like you know companies
ministries let's say municipalities
schools universities etc
to do good at scale
so let's say that a company like
let's say sisense want to volunteer with
600 employees you know um entire um you
know through the entire the whole year
so they use v in order to collect to
connect their employees to missions
around them and to get them together and
to record their hours and get texts for
funds etc so everything goes up to the
b2b side um but we are looking at feet
and how can we do this at scale
so we're going different from all of our
competitors that are going top down
direct to decision makers blah blah and
we're attacking this bottom up
super super scale um taking city by city
all over the world um and stuff
but it's definitely
possible and my why i mean where i came
you know the idea let's say or the
solution
um came from my experience managing
volunteers at first at the organization
that ran the competition
so when i um
as a student at first we had to give
back as a team to our local community to
participate in the competitions but
after a couple years we got an email
from first themselves requesting mai to
join the csr team
at first
they picked one student from each
country and i was the one from israel so
that was super cool
and this is where i was exposed to the
challenges and the potential of the csr
the corporate social responsibility
world and it was so early i'm talking
with you about 2016.
nothing before covet before everything
and now it's exploding every company
knows that it's a must-have thing to do
it now so it's
the transformation was crazy and we're
gonna be the technology that puts
everything together i love it i i want
to understand a little bit better i'll
i'll call the the consumer behavior if
you will you know traditional employees
yeah everyday people
i think that it speaks also to the
initial experience you've had with the
reception of of cutting your hair or or
generally giving back and sort of people
are are
underestimating the reason behind an
action and the why you're doing
something right and so here you're
effectively you know you're effectively
capitalizing on on human capital and and
people that are in organizations
with a very interesting bottom-ups
approach but at the end you have people
that are literally giving their time and
their energy through organizations to
volunteer their their their own
resources and so how do you what is sort
of the the consumer behavior piece of it
is there you know do you need to do a
lot of market education around this how
are people receptive to this new way
that they're going to be spending some
of their time within the organization
wow that's that's a great question that
we ask all the time like how to become
the consumer brand even more than the
you know employer brand because it's way
more in that side if they will want to
do it the problem is sold for the
company sure um
so uh so for us it comes in in many ways
so first of all we invest heavily on
brand and local brand for example now
we're on our on a mission to get uh to
make feed the number one platform in new
york and that's tough um so we're
starting to do many even you know um
local brand initiatives subway
um you know even like billboards these
are things that sas platforms do way way
way you know like lean in the right
um so so for us it's very very important
because we need the the actual users and
people to know us to trust us
we will know where to send them and what
to do with them um
and i will tell you something that i
found very interesting
um in fee is that
although v is a employee benefit product
today most of our users don't use v
during work
they take their kids
huh
they go with people outside of work
um and this is really interesting
because this actually brings us to
understand that we're solving a bigger
problem for the people that they not
necessarily want to go to volunteer only
with their colleagues this is something
that the employer wants them to do they
may not want to do that
um but they do want to go with their
kids or with their wife or their friends
um and this is where v comes in in a way
that because we're
our opportunities are so diverse all
around the world we now have over 1 000
missions live on the platform wow um
which is crazy we had 100
in the beginning of this year um so
having so many opportunities enable and
and give us the opportunity to even you
know explore more new you know use cases
um for example we have um a building
owner
that is giving v to the you know
residents
we would never think about that you know
starting so
um it's very interesting to see where
where it goes and and so just to make
sure excited
and
so you're talking about you know
building a brand which people trust and
people understand that they can that
they want to be part of it now when a
building owner
gives v to to their to their tenants you
know they they then can go and and
choose one of the thousand missions that
speaks to their own why right i mean and
i guess part of the part of the
understanding here is that our whys are
different you know we grow up in
different circumstances we perceive the
world in a different way but right but
i'm but i guess there is and we can
agree that every person has some why
that if we can just align that why with
a need that somebody else has then we
can find a huge win-win situation and in
his perspective we act you know pretty
much going off of like you know the
inspiration of sas companies which is
very non-traditional for
a
do such a doing good company like like v
then you're actually able to monetize
this and do it at scale right
yeah
i mean without connecting the y to a
need it is very very hard to scale it
from there so building the network for
us is just finding those wise fighting
no need those needs matching them
locally and this is
this is very very important people from
israel won't register to volunteer for a
non-profit from chicago i don't know
them i'm not gonna help them i want to
volunteer for something that is 10
minutes walk from my house that i know
the community i want to help them
there's a specific kid i want to help
and eventually when you're going to
think about it deeply we play we're like
a startup that is not playing with minds
we're playing with hearts
we know what things will shift and the
needle in the hearts of people in new
york
and eventually we'll be able to know
that you know which people will donate
to these causes
and we're gonna have many many data for
fundraising platforms and
um even you know politicians eventually
of which people care about these things
you're working on um so this is really
interesting to look at this and in this
angle um
but another thing that you may find
interesting is that it's not just the
cause
people rather volunteer with people that
invite them even if they don't it's not
their number one cause
um i would i'd rather to go or they're
going with uh with you to an opportunity
that you like and i'm okay with it okay
let's go clean the beach but i want to
do it with you
rather than go alone
to something that i care about so this
collectiveness and and it's very very
important and in the product we always
try to get people inviting each other
because then the conversion is over 90
percent of yes
so um
so this is also something that it very
important i love the the behavior
insights that you're bringing to at the
end it's figuring out okay you know
we're all you know we're all people
ultimately every person in the world we
will agree that innately we want to do
good we want to give back in some
capacity some people want to do it with
with resources financial some people
want to do with their time and you're
figuring out how do we how do we match a
person's trait how do we allow every
person with their own why and their own
capacity to do it whether it's in the 10
10 block radius of where they are
whether it's with their best friend
whether it's financially little with
donations and um and and i love sort of
the large-scale thinking that you're
bringing to this
and i'm personally very inspired by by
your story and you're you're doing so
much also giving back to the community
and the ecosystem here in israel and i'm
sure that's just the start and
my thank you very very much for the
great work that you're doing with v
thank you for letting me be a part of it
thank you for the 20 minutes here i
can't wait to share this with the world
and thank you very much and best of luck
thank you thank you so much michael
of course
[Music]